faubourg saint-honoré numéro 55 votre
nouvelle adresse monsieur le président
de la république l'elysée aujourd'hui
demeure officielle de tous les
présidents de la république française
l'elysée a été construit naguère pour
louis de la tour d'auvergne comte
d'evreux en 1720 oui 15 dirigeait alors
les affaires de l'état
à l'époque ce palais de l'elysée était
dit-on en plein champ à l'écart de paris
il n'en est plus de même aujourd'hui
au fil de l'histoire y séjournèrent la
pompadour favorite du roi le prince
murat napoléon 1er l'empereur qu'il
acheta pour sa chair joséphine puis le
duc de berry
puis louis napoléon bonaparte
prince-président jusqu'à son coup d'état
du 2 décembre 1851 puis ensuite les
républicains tiers batman grévy sadi
carnot
bref tous les présidents de la
république jusqu'à ce jour
voici monsieur le président de la
république l'elysée
tel qu'il voulons laisser
après le perron d'honneur le
traditionnel huissier hr
le grand escalier à palmer symbole de la
victoire
il conduit à votre étage laitages
présidentielle autres huissier à chaîne
autres gardes chargés de l'accueil des
visiteurs
le salon datant
bureau de vaud est deux camps
celui de vos très très très proches
collaborateurs au-delà de cette porte
le salon doré votre bureau monsieur le
président c'est ici que vous prendrez
vos grandes décisions
c'est ici que vous mais dit ray
c'est ici que vous consulterez les
grands dossiers de départ
c'est ici aussi sans doute que votre
regard s'attarde rats parfois sur ses
lustres et pop
cette savonnerie des gobelins
ces fauteuils de style
cette commode napoléon meubles qui
appartiennent tous à la république et
que vous pourrez changer à loisir en
puisant dans les réserves du mobilier
national
e
cette fenêtre donne sur le parc
éternellement calme à l'occasion vous y
verrez s'ébattre sur les deux hectares
de pelouse
les trois livriez offert au président
qu'on pidoux par le shah d'iran au bout
du parc
la célèbre dry du kop que seul peut
franchir les chefs d'état en visite
officielle
la façade 20 su toujours ensoleillé où
la lumière dit on est plus douce que
partout ailleurs dans l'elysée
l'ale privé
au premier les fenêtres de votre champ
par ses fenêtres qui vous permettront le
soir de découvrir les lumières et les
bruits de la ville où percevrait
peut-être en dépit de leur
traditionnelle discrétion
les gars de républicains qui lui est
jour veilleront sur votre sécurité
nul ne peut et vous le savez pénétrer
dans l'elysée sans s'être présenté
auparavant au poste le gard situé face
au bureau des inspecteurs de la sécurité
qu'il devait maintenant vont vous suivre
partout comme votre ou les oubliés
encore un instant aux charges futures et
vos contraintes et suivez nous sur
président l'elysée vaste de 1000 m² et
salons officiels nombreux eux aussi ont
leurs petites histoires
monsieur le président découvrez les avec
nous
le salon des portraits des visiteurs 10
yens
le salon de l'hémicycle l'ancienne
chambre de la pompadour tendu de bleu du
bleu tendre les yeux de la favorite de
louis 15 le salon des ambassadeurs
vous recevrez précisément et lettres de
créances des ambassadeurs nommés à paris
le salon 10 des aides de camp ce
napoléon
le salon murat sous le président sont
vides ou s'y tenait le traditionnel
conseil des ministres du mercredi
et
le salon d'argent historique
célèbre impérial
le 22 juin 1815 napoléon 1er il signa
son acte d'abdication au lendemain de
waterloo sous ses lambris dorés la
chapelle de l'elysée
tout petit
tout enfermé toute discrète
la chapelle juckes vos appartements
privés du rez de chaussée
tout y est résolument design est signé
pierre paulin le salon bibliothèque dans
les meubles sont incorporés au décor le
salon music avec le piano blanc la télé
et l'installation stéréophonique le
salon agam du nom de son auteur
yaacov agam peintres sculpteurs pour
l'oeil l'effet saisissant lumière
couleur ligne perspective
s'y côtoient dans la simplicité le
dépouillement de cet art nouveau qu'elle
dise à lumière voici monsieur le
président votre salle à manger privée
c'est d'oeuvres du sculpteur lalanne le
bar aux autruches
pour l'officiel et ses réceptions
permettez-nous monsieur le président de
présenter à votre épouse
la vaisselle signé par la manufacture
nationale de celle des services adaptés
et à café bleu de serre bien évidemment
les services de tard
d'après le catalogue officiel vous
conservateur il existe trois scieries
d'assiette la série dite paysages scènes
des fleuves
ou encore
la série dite des oiseaux
l'argenterie de l'elysée plus de 6000
pièces différentes
soigneusement répertoriés
les services en vermeil peu utilisé dans
ces cov couverts et assiettes
nous suivons pas à pas dans vos
déplacements en province et à l'étranger
pour vos réceptions officielles
la verrerie est en cristal de baccarat
quelque 3000 pièces fragiles fine taille
et et républicains
la grande cuisine
coeur de la réputation de votre table
les maîtres queux discret mais de
talents peuvent y préparer jusqu'à 200
couverts
le cuivre y est roi et porte encore les
marques de l'ancien régime
celle des maisons de compiègne
et le fontainebleau
la lingerie niché sous les toits des
centaines de paires de draps de
serviettes de là
on certaine aux 30 mètres de long
pour les grands dîners
et pour vos collaborateurs et votre
administration secrétaire fonctionnaires
téléphonistes des dizaines de bureaux
discret de part et d'autre de ce couloir
tout aussi discrète
e
notez bien monsieur le président 1 p r
64 p r comme présidence de la république
1 p r 75 le numéro minéralogique de
votre future voiture officielle
douze chevaux 2 tonnes six longueurs six
mètres cinquante trois largeurs de m 13
son moteur spécial permet de rouler au
pas à l'intérieur cuir fauve et gadgets
électriques ou fonctionnels l'elysée
compte pour tous ces services
une bonne trentaine de voitures dont
celle ci pour disons le vos déplacements
de tous les jours
non monsieur le président nous n'avons
rien oublié et surtout pas des grands
salons de l'elysée ou très bientôt se
déroulera la cérémonie d'investiture
celle du 20è président de la république
française la vôtre monsieur le président
m